48 horas después de la mayor operación
militar de Israel en 20 años su enlaces
Jordania ocupada Esto es lo que queda en
las calles de llenín escombros y
ambulancias de la media luna roja
Palestina que ahora pueden patrullar
libremente luego de La progresiva
retirada del ejército israelí las
consecuencias de la incursión serán
difíciles de borrar según la autoridad
Palestina las fuerzas de ocupación han
causado grandes daños a la
infraestructura del agua electricidad y
alcantarillado en el campamento de
refugiados y sus alrededores lo que
puede causar una catástrofe sanitaria el
pueblo palestino denuncia que las
fuerzas israelíes atacaron y obstruyeron
deliberadamente el paso de las
ambulancias impidiendo atender a los
heridos este padre llora la muerte de su
hijo quien perdió la vida mientras
trasladaba a un amigo al hospital su
amigo resultó herido lo vimos corriendo
hacia el hospital decía quiero ir al
hospital quiero ir al hospital Le dije
que no fuera tenía la sensación de que
algo sucedería pero Israel niega haber
atacado civiles esta operación es solo
contra la infraestructura terrorista
dentro del campamento de yening no es
una invasión no es contra la autoridad
Palestina no es contra las fuerzas
palestinas
sis Jordania vive su mayor pico de
violencia desde la segunda enfada solo
en 2023 cerca de 200 palestinos han
muerto por enfrentamientos con Israel
las milicias palestinas entre ellas
jamás y la yihadi islámica prometieron
responder a la agresión israelí y un
ataque ante la VIP sería la prueba
mientras que los palestinos en el exilio
protestan por la complicidad de las
Naciones Árabes en lo que consideran un
crimen de guerra
[Aplausos]